avec un clou
[Musique]
le jeu de bisous c'est pareil je lui dis
nous c'est très simple vous avez tous un
rouge à lèvres devant vous je vais vous
poser des questions sur l'actualité des
médias d'accord avant d'accueillir
bertrand chamerois dès que vous avez la
bonne réponse vous lever la main vous
mettez d'ailleurs mettez tous déjà
beaucoup de rouge à lèvres dès
maintenant mettez sans vraiment beaucoup
parce que vous allez devoir embrasser
complètement le visage de la personne
que vous voulez éliminer et j'espère que
gilles verdez va donner mais qui a dit
la chaîne est venu me chercher au fond
du ruisseau quatre propositions
thierry ardisson michel denisot maïtena
biraben ou yann barthès ardisson kerry
ardisson s'étire ardisson cadix assure
qu'à la place jean luc lemoine dirigez
vous vers la personne que vous voulez
éliminer que vous aller embrasser de
partout
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quelle émission de télé va être
suspendue vu à la télé face à la bande
vos objets aussi une histoire dont un
soir à la tour eiffel et montre au mieux
à la prairie clown vu à la télé gym
werder éliminé quelqu'un ça y est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
valérie bénaïm on peut pas la louper les
vraiment il est vide rien elle est
embrassée par gilles verdez il y en a
mis partout partout partout partout
attention aux joues pour deux bisous sur
celle là dimanche soir bernard de la
villardière présentait un enquête
exclusive intitulé l'île nouveau défi
pour la brigade des stups
mais quel était le titre prévu
initialement déjà tous les deux éliminés
est ce que vous n'avez pas attendu la
question attention lille la ville du
péché qui complique plaque tournante de
la drogue et de la prostitution
prostitution drogue et violent lille la
ville où ça bouge ou cannabis héroïne
ecstasy lille capitale de la déception
cannabis héroïne ecstasy ville capitale
de l'inde et font exactement jean luc
lemoine donc c'est gagner vous pouvez
embrasser deux personnes éliminées deux
personnes
jean luc lemaire chargé
[Applaudissements]
regardez vers des canaux
qui a dit peut-être que je ferai une
pause du journal david pujadas daphné
roulier claire chazal ou laurent
delahousse c'est vous qui avez une fois
je vous jure que si jean louis laurent
delahousse laurent delahousse était plus
rapide
et quelque chose
john n aura servi gens très sérieux les
mines c'est rien c'est cervélo tu me
dégoûtes
[Musique]